we start off with singer our Kelly who
is back in custody this time facing
federal sex crimes charges NYPD
detectives and homeland security agents
arrested Kelly last night in Chicago he
was indicted earlier in the day by two
federal courts the Northern District of
Illinois based in Chicago and the
Eastern District of New York based in
Brooklyn the 13 count indictment accuses
Kelly of charges related to child
pornography enticement of a minor and
obstruction of justice and this is on
top of the state charges he already
faces CTM national correspondent Jericka
Duncan has been covering the allegations
of abuse by our Kelly which he strongly
denies we should point out Jericka what
else do we know well this is the first
time that our Kelly is facing federal
charges we heard that this was coming it
was really a matter of when federal
prosecutors in New York are expected to
announce charges as early as today which
our sources say could involve sex
trafficking for the second time this
year R&B singer R Kelly was arrested in
Chicago on sex crime charges
federal agents took the three-time
Grammy winner into custody sources say
it happened while he was walking his dog
in front of his Trump Tower apartment
Thursday night and four more charges
even if you're innocent
Kelly's crisis manager Darrell Johnson
says the singers team was expecting
federal charges and they are ready to
fight them so there's a lot of fans a
lot of people praying for him and
they're wishing him the best and you
know the best outcome is going to be out
and that's what we all hope Kelly had
already been charged with a number of
sex related crimes this year the new
indictment alleges additional counts
just six weeks ago he pleaded not guilty
to eleven of those charges in Chicago
four of which carry up to 30 years in
prison each if convicted in an explosive
interview with Gayle King in March
Kelly insisted he has done nothing wrong
and denied allegations he abused women
well I'm stupid with never helping our
Kelly with all I've been through in my
way way
Pass to hold somebody let alone four or
five 650 you say it
how stupid would I be to do that this
camera on me yes that's stupid
use your common sense the singer has
denied allegations of sexual misconduct
for decades and was acquitted on state
child pornography charges in 2008 our
Kelly has pleaded not guilty to all
previous charges against him it's
unclear whether these new federal
charges like the obstruction of justice
charge are related to the previous ones
we don't know yet when Kelly will appear
before a judge next Anthony Jericka
thank you